white supremacists marched in Washington
D.C wearing masks by the way I guess
they're not that confident in the world
knowing who they are and what they
believe there's a Newsweek report
um hundreds of white supremacists march
on Capital with shields and battle drums
we'll look at a video in a moment video
posted to social media showed hundreds
of members of the white supremacist
group Patriot front marched to the
United States capital carrying Shields
and battle drums on Saturday by the way
I hear sometimes supremacists pronounced
supremacist
like I think Lindsey Graham says it that
way and some others I don't know where
they're getting supremaced supremacist
is the word at least 150 members of the
far-right group wearing masks to conceal
their identity were seen marching along
the National Mall and in downtown DC
videos posted to Twitter showed them
carrying American flags and holding
signs that read reclaim America the
March comes as experts warn about the
rise of white supremacist groups and
sentiment in the U.S according to a
study from the Anti-Defamation League
from March a 38 increase in white
supremacist activity was seen from 2021
to 2022 with more than 67 incidents
reported throughout the year in the
videos police officers are seen
escorting Patriot front members to
separate them from counter protesters so
we have a video here I will describe it
for the people that are only listening
today you do indeed see a police sort of
escort I think is on bikes around the
Patriot front guys they all seem to be
wearing I guess the uniform they've
chosen is tight khaki pants although I
don't know that they're supposed to be
tight some of them may just have pants
that are too small tight khaki pants and
then blue shirts masks and hats they are
Marching they are carrying Shields
let's listen right
now as we continue to watch this and you
see the police escort closing around
them
what is the deal with the shields
I don't know
wow
and off they go
why do they hide their identities
clearly they realize there might be real
world consequences to being identified
as
white supremacists I don't know
all right so if you look online there's
a bunch of magas convinced that this is
a false flag event now what they mean by
that I don't really know I guess what
they're saying is it's a false flag in
that these aren't really white
supremacists
this is actually
antifa or I don't know BLM or Hunter
Biden's extended family I don't know
it's people pretending to be white
supremacists
and white supremacists don't really
exist maybe I I don't really know but
you would then ask yourself if it's a
false flag they should have no problem
denouncing what they stand for even if
they're pretending to stand for that but
they don't do that either
it's all very weird but white
supremacists marching in DC with uh
tight pants boots masks Flags some of
the flags upside down and a uh extremely
extremely solid police escort I must say